hey 42 here the founder of matcom gary
Kremen lost his girlfriend's to a man
she met on match.com welcome to RIF
the Sun's core is so hot that a piece of
it the size of a pinhead would give off
enough heat to kill a person a hundred
and sixty kilometers away women by
eighty percent of everything that is for
sale which means that eight out of every
ten purchases made around the world in a
single day are made by women
um can survive in a microwave because
they are small enough to dodge the Rays
the Great Pyramids used to be white as
snow because they were encased in a
bright lime stone that has worn off over
the years jellyfish evaporate in the Sun
because they're 98% water in the course
of an average lifetime you will whilst
sleeping eat 70 assorted insects and ten
spiders a person can live without food
for about a month but only about a week
without water if the amount of water in
your body is reduced by just one percent
you'll feel thirsty if it's reduced by
ten percent
you'll die hot water is heavier than
cold water because it contains more
energy
elephants can die from a broken heart
they are highly emotional animals and
will mourn the loss of loved ones often
going into withdrawal which sometimes
causes death there is a term for the
opposite of ambidextrous it's ambien
astir and it means you're equally crap
with both hands thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you